[MUSIC PLAYING]
JEN GENNAI: I'm an
operations manager,
so my role is to ensure that
we're making our considerations
around ethically AI
deliberate, actionable,
and scalable across the
whole organization in Google.
So one of the first
things to think about
if you're a business
leader or a developer
is ensuring that people
understand what you stand for.
What does ethics mean to you?
For us, that meant setting
values-driven principles
as a company.
These value-driven
principles, for us,
are known as our AI principles.
And last year, we
announced them in June.
So these are seven guidelines
around AI development
and deployment, which
assigned to us how
we want to develop AI.
We want to ensure that we're not
creating or reinforcing bias.
We want to make sure that
we're building technology
that's accountable to people.
And we have five others
here that you can read.
It's available on our website.
But at the same time
that we announce
these aspirational
principles for the company,
we also identified
four areas that we
have considered our red lines.
So these are technologies
that we will not pursue.
These cover things like
weapons technology.
We will not build
or deploy weapons.
We will also not build
or deploy technologies
that we feel violate
international human rights.
So if you're a business
leader or a developer,
we'd also encourage
you to understand what
are your aspirational goals.
But at the same time,
what are your guardrails?
What point are you're
not going to cross?
It's the most important thing
to do, is to know what is
your definition of
ethical AI development.
After you've set
your AI principles,
the next thing is, how
do you make them real?
How do you make sure that you're
aligning with those principles?
So here, there are
three main things
I'd suggest keeping in mind.
The first one is you need an
accountable and authoritative
body.
So for us in Google, this means
that we have senior executives
across the whole company
who have the authority
to approve or decline a launch.
So they have to
wrestle with some
of these very complex
ethical questions
to ensure that we
are launching things
that we do believe will lead
to fair and ethical outcomes.
So they provide the authority
and the accountability
to make some really
tough decisions.
Secondly, you have to make sure
that the decision-makers have
the right information.
This involves talking to diverse
people within the company,
but also listening to
your external users,
external stakeholders,
and feeding that
into your
decision-making criteria.
Jamila will talk
more about engaging
with external
communites in a moment.
And then the third key
part of building governance
and accountability
is having operations.
Who's going to do the work?
What are the structures
and frameworks
that are repeatable,
that are transparent,
and that are understood
by the people who
are making these decisions?
So for that, in Google, we've
established a central team
that's not based in our
engineering and product teams
to ensure that there's a
level of objectivity here.
So the same people who
are building the products
are not the only
people who are looking
to make sure that those
products are fair and ethical.
So now you have your
principles that you're
trying to ensure that
people understand
what does ethics mean for you.
We're talking about establishing
governance structure
to make sure that you're
achieving those goals,
and the next thing to do is to
ensure that you're encouraging
everyone within your company or
the people that you work with
and for are aligned
on those goals.
So making sure, one, that you've
set overall goals in alignment
with ethical AI--
so how are you going to
achieve ethical development
and deployment of technology?
Next, you want to make sure
that you're training people
to think about these
issues from the start.
You don't want to catch
some ethical consideration
late in the product
development lifecycle.
You want to make
sure that you're
starting that as early
as possible-- so getting
people trained to think
about these types of issues.
Then we have rewards.
You have to make sure
if you're holding people
accountable to ethical
development and deployment,
you may have to accept
that that might slow down
some development in order to
get to the right outcomes--
making sure people feel
rewarded for thinking
about ethical development
and deployment.
And then, finally, making
sure that you're hiring people
and developing people
who are helping you
achieve those goals.
Next, you've established
your frameworks,
you've hired the right
people, you're rewarding them.
How do you know you're
achieving your goals?
So we think about this as
validating and testing.
So an example here
is replicating
a user's experience.
Who are your users?
How do you make sure
that you're thinking
about a representative
sample of your users?
So you think about trying to
test different experiences,
mostly from your core subgroups.
But you also want to
be thinking about,
who are your marginalized users?
Who might be underrepresented
in your workforce?
And therefore, you might have
to pay additional attention to
to get it right.
We also think about, what
are the failure modes?
And what we mean by that is
if people have been negatively
affected by a
product in the past,
we want to make sure they
won't be negatively affected
in the future.
So how do we learn
from that and make sure
that we're testing deliberately
for that in the future?
And then the final bit
of testing and validation
is introducing some
of those failures
into the product to make sure
that you're stress testing,
and, again, have
some objectivity
to stress test a product
to make sure it's achieving
your fair and ethical goals.
And then we think about
it's not just you.
You're not alone.
How do we ensure that we're
all sharing information
to make us more fair and
ethical and to make sure
that the products we deliver
are fair and ethical?
So we encourage the sharing of
best practices and guidelines.
We do that ourselves
in Google by providing
our research and best practices
on the Google AI site.
So these best practices
cover everything
from ML fairness
tools and research
that Margaret Mitchell will
talk about in a moment,
but also best practices
and guidelines
that any developer or
any business leader
could follow themselves.
So we try to both provide
that ourselves, as well
as encouraging other people
to share their research
and learnings also.
So with that, as we talk
about sharing with external,
it's also about
bringing voices in.
So I'll pass over
to Jamila Smith-Loud
to talk about understanding
human impacts.
JAMILA SMITH-LOUD: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Hi, everyone.
I'm going to talk
to you a little bit
today about understanding,
conceptualizing, and assessing
human consequences and impacts
on real people and communities
through the use of tools
like social equity impact
assessments.
Social and equity
impact assessments
come primarily from the
social science discipline
and give us a
research-based method
to assess these questions in
a way that is broad enough
to be able to apply
across products,
but also specific enough
for us to think about what
are tangible product changes and
interventions that we can make.
So I'll start off with
one of the questions
that we often start when
thinking about these questions.
I always like to
say that when we're
thinking about ethics, when
we're thinking about fairness,
and even thinking about
questions of bias,
these are really
social problems.
And one major entry point into
understanding social problems
is really thinking about what's
the geographic context in which
users live, and how does
that impact their engagement
with the product?
So really asking,
what experiences
do people have that are based
solely on where they live
and that may differ greatly
for other peoples who
live in different
neighborhoods that are either
more resourced, more
connected to internet-- all
of these different aspects that
make regional differences so
important?
Secondly, we like to ask what
happens to people when they're
engaging with our
products in their families
and in their communities.
We like to think about, what
are economic changes that
may come as a part of engagement
with this new technology?
What are social and cultural
changes that really do impact
how people view the technology
and view their participation
in the process?
And so I'll start a little bit
of talking about our approach.
The good thing
about utilizing kind
of existing frameworks of social
and equity impact assessments
which come from--
if you think about when
we do new land development
projects or even
environmental assessments,
there's already the standard
of considering social impacts
as a part of that process.
And so we really do think of
employing new technologies
in the same way.
We should be asking similar
questions about how communities
are impacted, what
are their perceptions,
and how are they framing
these engagements?
And so one of the things
that we think about
are kind of what is a
principled approach to asking
these questions?
And the first one
really is around
engaging in the hard questions.
When we're talking
about fairness,
when we're talking
about ethics, we're
not talking about
them separately
from issues of racism,
social class, homophobia,
and all forms of
cultural prejudice.
We're talking about what
are the issues as they
overlay in those systems.?
And so it really
requires us to be
OK with those hard questions,
and engaging with them,
and realizing that our
technologies and our products
don't exist separately
from that world.
The next approach is really
towards thinking anticipatory.
I think the different
thing about thinking
about social and equity
impact assessments
from other social
science research methods
is that the relationships
between causal impacts
and correlations are going
to be a little bit different,
and we really are
trying to anticipate
harms and consequences.
And so it requires you to be OK
with the fuzzy conversations,
but also realize that
there's enough research,
there's enough
data that gives us
the understanding of how history
and contexts impact outcomes.
And so being anticipatory
in your process
is really, really an
important part of it.
And lastly, in terms of thinking
about the principled approach
is really centering the
voices and experiences
of those communities who
often bear the burden
of the negative impacts.
And that requires
understanding how
those communities would even
conceptualize these problems.
I think sometimes we come
from a technical standpoint,
and we think about
the communities
as separate from the problem.
But if we're ready to center
those voices and engaged
throughout the whole
process, I think
it results in better outcomes.
So to go a little bit
deeper into engaging
in the hard questions, what
we're really trying to do
is be able to assess how
a product will impact
communities,
particularly communities
who have been historically and
traditionally marginalized.
So it requires us
to really think
about history and context.
How is that shaping this
issue, and what could we
learn from that assessment?
It also requires an
intersectional approach.
If we're thinking
about gender equity,
if we're thinking
about racial equity,
these are not issues
that live separately.
They really do
intersect, and being OK
with understanding of that
intersectional approach
allows for a much
fuller assessment.
And then, lastly, in thinking
about new technologies
and thinking about
new products, how does
power influence outcomes and the
feasibility of interventions?
I think that the question
of power and social impact
go hand-in-hand,
and it requires us
to be OK with [? answering. ?]
Answering might not
get the best
answer, but at least
asking those hard questions.
So our anticipatory process is
part of a full process, right?
So it's not just us thinking
about the social and equity
impacts, but it really
is thinking about them
within the context
of the product--
so really having domain-specific
application of these questions,
and then having some
assessment of the likelihood
of the severity of the risk.
And then, lastly, thinking
about what are meaningful
mitigations for whatever impacts
that we have to developed.
And so it's a full process.
It requires work on
our team in terms
of understanding
in the assessment,
but it also requires partnership
with our product teams
to really do that
domain-specific analysis.
Centering the assessment.
I talked a little bit
about this before,
but when we're centering
this assessment, really,
what we're trying to ask
is, who's impacted most?
So if we're thinking
about a problem that
may have some
economic impact, it
would require us to
disaggregate the data based
on income to see what
communities, what populations,
are most impacted-- so being OK
with thinking about it in very
specific population
data and understanding
who is impacted the most.
Another important
part is validation.
And I think Jen mentioned
that a lot, but really
thinking about community-based
research engagements,
whether that's a
participatory approach,
whether that's focus groups.
But really, how do we
validate our assessments
by engaging communities
directly and really centering
their framing of the problem
as part of our project?
And then going through
iteration and realizing
that it's not going to be
perfect the first time, that it
requires some pull and
tugging from both sides
to really get the
conversation right.
So what types of social
problems are we thinking of?
We're thinking about
income inequality, housing
and displacement,
health disparities,
the digital divide,
and food access.
We're thinking about these and
all different types of ways,
but I thought it
might be helpful
if we thought about
a specific example.
So let's look at
the example of one
of the types of social
problems that we
want to understand in relation
to our products and users.
The topic of inequity
related to food access, which
this map shows you--
and it's definitely a
US context that we're
thinking about this
question for now,
but also always thinking
about it from a global way.
But I thought that this
map was a good way for us
to look at it.
As you can see, the areas
that are shaded darker
are the areas where those users
might have a significantly
different experience when we're
thinking about products that
give personalization and
recommendations maybe
for something like restaurants.
So we're thinking
about questions
about how those users are
either included or excluded
from the product
experience, and then we're
thinking about going even
further and thinking about how
small businesses and
low resource businesses
also impact that
type of product.
So it requires us to
realize that there's
a wealth of data that
allows us to even go here as
deep as the census tract level
and understand that there are
certain communities who
have a significantly
different experience
than other communities.
And so, like I said,
this map is looking
at communities at a
census tract level
where there's no car
and no supermarket
store within a mile.
And if we want it
to look even deeper,
we can overlay this
information with income.
So thinking about food
access and income disparity,
which are often
connected, gives us
a better understanding of
how different groups may
engage with a product.
And so when thinking about a
hard social problem like this,
it really requires
us to think, what's
the logical process
for us to get
towards a big social problem
and have very specific outcomes
and effects that are meaningful
and are making a change?
And it requires us
to really acknowledge
that there's contexts
that overlays
all parts of this process,
from the inputs that we have,
from the activities that we
do-- which may, in my case,
be very much
research-based activities--
and then thinking about
what are meaningful outputs.
And so to go in a
little bit deeper
in kind of this logic model
way of thinking about it,
we have a purpose now, in
thinking about the food access
example, to reduce negative
unintended consequences
in areas where access to
quality food is an issue.
We're also very
aware of the context.
So we're thinking about
the context of food access,
but we're also thinking about
questions of gentrification.
We're thinking
about displacement.
We're thinking about
community distrust.
So we realize that
this question has
many other issues that
inform the context, not just
access to food.
But as part of the process,
we're identifying resources.
We're thinking, where are there
multidisciplinary research
teams that can help
us think through?
What are our external
stakeholders that
can help us frame the problem?
And then, what are the
cross-functional relationships
that we need to
build to really be
able to solve this
kind of problem,
while acknowledging what
our constraints are?
Oftentimes, time is
a huge constraint,
and then gaps just in
knowledge and comfort
in being able to talk
about these hard problems.
Some of the
activities and inputs
that we are thinking
about can help
us get to some
answers are really
thinking about case studies,
thinking about surveys,
thinking about user research
where we're asking user
perception about this issue.
How does engagement
based on your geography
differ in being able
to do that analysis?
And then creating
tangible outputs,
some that are product
interventions and really
focused on how we can make
changes to the product,
but also really community-based
mitigations in thinking about
are there ways in
which we're engaging
with the community, ways
in which we're pulling data
that we can really use to create
a fuller set of solutions.
And really, it's always towards
aspiring for positive effects
in principle and practice.
So this is one of
those areas where
you can feel like you have
a very principled approach,
but it really is about being
able to put them into practice.
And so some of the things
that I'll leave you
with today in thinking
about understanding
these human impacts are really
being able to apply them
and thinking about applying
them in specific technical
applications,
building trust through
equitable collaboration--
so really thinking about,
when you're engaging with
external stakeholders,
how do you make
it feel equitable
and that we're both
sharing knowledge
and experiences in ways
that are meaningful--
and then validating the
knowledge generation.
When we're engaging with
different communities,
we really have to be OK that
information, data, and the way
that we frame this can come
from multiple different sources,
and it's really important.
And then really thinking about,
within your organization,
within your team,
what are change agents
and what are change
instruments that really
make it a meaningful process?
Thank you.
Now Margaret will talk more
about the machine learning
pipeline.
[APPLAUSE]
MARGARET MITCHELL: Great.
Thanks, Jamila.
So I'll be talking a bit about
fairness and transparency
and some frameworks and
approaches for developing
ethical AI.
So in a typical machine
learning development pipeline,
the starting point for
developers is often the data.
Training data is first
collected and annotated.
From there, a model
can be trained.
The model can then be
used to output content
such as predictions or rankings,
and then downstream users
will see the output.
And we often see
this approach as
if it's a relatively
clean pipeline that
provides objective information
that we can act on.
However, from the
beginning of this pipeline,
human bias has already shaped
the data that's collected.
Human bias then further
shapes what we collect
and how we annotate it.
Here are some of the human
biases that commonly contribute
to problematic biases and
data, and in the interpretation
of model outputs.
Things like reporting bias--
where we tend to remark
on things that are
noticeable to us,
as opposed to things
that are typical--
things like out-group
homogeneity bias--
where we tend to see people
outside of our social group
as somehow being
less nuanced or less
complex than people within
the group that we work with--
and things like
automation bias--
where we tend to favor
the outputs of systems
that are automated over the
outputs of what humans actually
say even when there's
contradictory information.
So rather than this
straightforward, clean,
end-to-end pipeline,
we have human bias
coming in at the
start of the cycle,
and then being propagated
throughout the rest
of the system.
And this creates a
feedback loop where,
as users see the output of
biased systems and start
to click or start to
interact with those outputs,
this then feeds data
that is further trained
on-- that's already been
biased in this way--
creating problematic
feedback loops
where biases can
get worse and worse.
We call this a sort of
bias network effect,
or bias "laundering."
And a lot of our work
seeks to disrupt this cycle
so that we can bring the
best kind of output possible.
So some of the
questions we consider
is, who is at the table?
What are the priorities
in what we're working on?
Should we be thinking
about different aspects
of the problem and different
perspectives as we develop?
How is the data that we're
working with collected?
What kind of things
does it represent?
Are there problematic
correlations in the data?
Or are some kinds of subgroups
underrepresented in a way
that will lead to
disproportionate errors
downstream?
What are some foreseeable risks?
So actually thinking
with foresight
and anticipating possible
negative consequences
of everything that we work on
in order to better understand
how we should prioritize.
What constraints and
supplements should be in place?
Beyond a basic machine
learning system,
what can we do to ensure
that we can account
for the kinds of risks
that we've anticipated
and can foresee?
And then what can we share
with you, the public,
about this process?
We aim to be transparent
as we can about this
in order to bring about
information about how we're
focusing on this and make
it clear that this is part
of our development lifecycle.
I'm going to briefly talk about
some technical approaches.
This is in the research world.
You can look at papers on
this, if you're interested,
for more details.
So there are two sorts of ML--
Machine Learning--
techniques that we've
found to be relatively useful.
One is bias mitigation,
and the other one we've
been broadly calling inclusion.
So bias mitigation focuses
on removing a signal
for problematic variables.
So for example,
say you're working
on a system that is supposed
to predict whether or not
someone should be promoted.
You want to make sure
that that system is not
keying on something like gender,
which we know is correlated
with promotion decisions.
In particular, women are
less likely to be promoted
or are promoted less quickly
than men in a lot of places,
including in tech.
We can do this using an
adversarial multi-task learning
framework where, while
we predict something
like getting promoted,
we also try and predict
the subgroup that we'd like
to make sure isn't affecting
the decision and
discourage the model
from being able to see that,
removing the representation
by basically reversing the
gradient and backpropagating.
When we work on
inclusion, we're working
on adding signal for
something-- trying to make sure
that there are subgroups
that are accounted for,
even if they're not
well-represented in the data.
And one of the approaches that
works really well for this
is transfer learning.
So we might take a
pre-trained network
with some understanding
of gender,
for example, or some
understanding of skin tone,
and use that in
order to influence
the decisions of
another network that
is able to key on these
representations in order
to better understand nuances in
the world that it's looking at.
This is a little bit
of an example of one
of the projects I was working on
where we were able to increase
how well we could detect whether
or not someone was smiling
based on working with some
consented gender-identified
individuals and having
representations of what
these gender presentations
looked like, using that
within the model that then
predicted whether or not
someone was smiling.
Some of the
transparency approaches
that we've been working on
help to further explain to you
and also help keep us
accountable for doing
good work here.
So one of them is model cards.
In model cards, we're
focusing on reporting
what model performance
is, disaggregating
across various subgroups, and
making it clear that we've
taken ethical
considerations into account,
making it clear
what the intended
applications of the
model or the API is,
and sharing, generally,
different kinds
of considerations that
developers should keep in mind
as they work with the models.
Another one is data cards.
And this provides
evaluation data about,
when we report numbers,
what is this based on?
Who is represented when we
decide a model can be used--
that it's safe for use?
These kinds of things are useful
for learners-- so people who
generally want to
better understand
how models are working and
what are the sort of things
that are affecting model
performance for third party
users.
So non-ML professionals
who just want
to have a better
understanding of their data
sets that they're working with
or what the representation
is in different data sets that
machine learning models are
based on or evaluated
on, as well as machine
learning researchers.
So people like me, who want to
compare model performance, they
want to understand what
needs to be improved,
what is already
doing well, and help
be able to sort of
benchmark and make progress
in a way that's sensitive
to the nuanced differences
in different kinds
of populations.
Our commitment to
you, working on
fair and ethical artificial
intelligence and machine
learning, is to continue
to measure, to improve,
and to share real-world
impact related to ethical AI
development.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]